staying in washington prosecutors are
seeking the longest sentence yet for a
january 6 rioter in the case of thomas
webster he's a former new york city
police officer convicted of attacking
other officers at the u.s capitol scott
mcfarland is across the way on capitol
hill for us scott good morning
tony good morning to you the case of
thomas webster has always been among the
highest profile january six cases
because he's a former new york officer
and was a member of then mayor michael
bloomberg's security detail but also
because he wore his nypd bulletproof
vest here january 6
and swung a flagpole so forcefully at
police he broke the pole then tackled
and dragged an officer
a jury rejected his claims of
self-defense at trial and convicted him
just a matter of hours of deliberation
here today the justice department will
ask a judge to sentence thomas webster
to 17 plus years in prison that that'd
be nearly double the longest sentence in
any january 6 case so far and they argue
it's justified partly because of the
body armor the weapon he wielded and
that he came here ready for battle that
day a 17-year sentence would also raise
the bar for other defendants still to
come including the accused oath keepers
seditious conspiracy defendants who are
also accused of coming here ready for
battle they go on trial next month there
are roughly 860 defendants so far in the
capital riot from nearly all 50 states
and there are
hundreds more arrests expected in the
future
gail wow
scott thank you very much